you
hello my name is international arbiter
my comer or I can see live from the st.
Louis chess club I'm here today to
promote intense chess while I was
directing a tournament in Las Vegas the
millionaire chess tournament which was a
big success and while I was there I
noticed something very particular about
the players in the open section the time
control for the event was 40 moves in 90
minutes and then sudden death in 30
minutes and each time he hit the clock
you get an additional 30 second
increment so what would happen is each
player would get down to about 10
minutes on the clock and have to make
ten moves to hit their first time
control
and so alright there was a big flurry of
action very intense and very cool and
then they would hit time control I make
the 40th move they would wander around
get something to eat and then sure
enough they both have five minutes left
on their time control and you know there
just be duking it out playing on the
increment so the game would last roughly
about four and a half hours so here's my
idea why not just condense it you know
to to win intense chest using the action
clock which also incorporates a big part
of the new style of poker where they
have action clock and time extensions
okay so the standard time control for
intense chess would be each side starts
with two thirty second time extensions
in their time bank and they have a ten
second action clock so unlike regular
blitz chess where it's just back and
forth back and forth where you know the
game is going to be over ten minutes
these guys can actually sit down and
think you know as long as they play a
move within that ten seconds they'll
still have one minute in their time bank
to really make some good decisions so
let's go to my game against national
master Julian Pro leeko and see how that
one plays out Here I am with the
national master Julian Pro League oh I
am of course international arbiter
Michael J comer and we are playing the
first game of intense chest
we each start with two 30-second time
banks that equal a minute and we have a
ten second action clock are you ready
obviously I'd then start me up
all right I witnessed joel benjamin play
gata Kamsky in this game so good luck
yes pin Ches I'm sure it happened US
Chess Championship
unfortunately white did not win but he
got a good position out of it do not
want to go on and on my time bank
already but unfortunately I have to
oh you want double puns deal yeah deal
of a lifetime
and just like gotta calm ski I am NOT
gonna let you castle can we just go back
to see one and be happy
please please please do whatever you
everyone like Oh Mike likes going
alright though I have there's a
threesome see two seconds oh yeah I was
bluffing bluffing boy yes so so no clock
can really do what we really wanted to
do like there should be an action clock
for both sides going on not just one
because it's very very confusing without
the technology we have right now very
confusing
all right you forced me to play g3i I'll
play it and he castles long right into
my trap
Mike do you see my queens on the same
line is your guys so bad news alright I
did not I got the trash talk and I did
not have to use any of my time paying
for that
so that's success that's like stuff oh
oh it wasn't oh yes yes yes
it's finished variances okay get into
that time bank get into the time bank
Julian we're just barely didn't you and
now I have your pawn oh no I have on one
eye one that I wanted whoa-oh-oh-oh no
Julian
IOP use any of his time Bank you just he
just threw out he five thought he had
all his bases covered but little does he
know little did he know he didn't have
any of his bases covered and they call
him national master that's what they
call me
Oh Oh Red Alert red alert alert but just
because somebody sacrifices a piece
doesn't mean I have to take especially
when I have to check right no I don't I
don't want that rook anyway I don't want
him I don't want him check away from a
coin one away I'm one away one away yeah
I told you I didn't care about that
check but you didn't listen you just
didn't listen no my mother always told
me I was about this she knew what she
was saying and it's usually fathers
knows best but no in this case all right
give me a pretty queen yes jack oh I
don't care about that I don't care about
that
I can't block with that Queen anyway I
can alright I'm out of that I'm out of
Dodge you can have that and now of
course I'm gonna slam this move but I'm
not just joking
uh-oh dude don't even think about it
alright he's not thinking about it I
could do a scary movie
am I going right there you'd be so
scared in atomic could probably be Oh
any mother no wait don't check me with
that night okay that's the deal you do
not get to check me with that night
please don't check me with that night
deal
okay good no he's raised him a time bank
he's in that time bank
yeah yeah
all right all right this is great this
is great
you attacked my dude yeah I don't like
them I don't like them
this is greatness is great got see
everything I ever wanted in opposition
why do you want to our you want you wait
what
don't even joke about anything I just
kind of take I'm just gonna take oh
you're a lad that was your plan you know
your plan had many many flaws I don't
know which camera I'm supposed to be
talking to but many plus oh yeah many
flaws many flaws many flaws yes come on
be nice be nice Oh shucks
alright check not see that move but but
whatever he got lucky he got like
is that gonna be checkmate them and then
you check and it's remove the defender
all right I got one move I just play it
I guess never make that move never make
that move it played the best move on the
board he played the best move on the
board oh my god so he went from keen
checkmated to possibly being the one
give me that check of me it could go
either way folks he could go either way
okay coming and he's only guys in this
time Bank he's this time Bank oh my god
the twenty seconds
there's nothing he's in his final time
Bank yeah it took the took the coward's
way out
likes coward's way out yeah I would
think so in front of the national
audience and national audience it could
be an international oh that could be the
winning move could be what was what was
that hey I made a move she made a move
it's your move
oh and I only got done Ellis's just
everybody attack everybody attack
everybody let's get it crazy let's get
it crazy deflection deflection
deflection six seconds left what all
right you got oh I still got a pawn I
still got a pawn
oh god why oh but he's got a pawn
everybody's got a pawn
now I got two pawns left and I get that
guy he's alright
I should have never told you were
playing in front of a national audience
an international international that's
what really really got clover here you
can take it everyone yeah I would've
died with I'm lazy he's not here kings
of the court I could checkmate them I
could show you I'll keep my little night
whatever I don't want to get blown out
here oh it's got a little position even
I can figure this one out
alright I give up good game to only all
right Julian just got me Beverly but uh
when you see how he had a good advantage
for most of the game but because of the
intensity when he was actually using his
time extensions it really got the better
of him and I almost came back to win so
that was a lot of fun so let's go to the
quick game which we only have one time
extension to start with uh 30 seconds
but still have ten seconds on our action
clock so we saw the game against Julian
that kind of the standard now we will
have a quick version of the game where
we only start with one additional time
Bank of thirty seconds and the action
clock again is just ten seconds so it
will be intense here's my opponent Mario
Roper not titled so hopefully I can get
a grin or something if you're ready
Mario go ahead and start me up here we
go
10 seconds to think about it right all
right I cannot resist the Chuck I cannot
resist the check but somehow I did tax
my palm protected the palm this is
really good pacing more like a tennis
match then uh then just sit around and
watch the game you know very good pacing
are y'all castles unlike
she won't answer how's my chance now is
my chance
why are you going to his time bank oh
just in the nick of time just in the
nick of time
you touched it it's going backwards he's
going backwards
and he is officially into his tank and
he should have thought long around I
guess he got lucky did he get lucky
let's check
it's better work
give the man a check
you know
very disappointing very disappoint
vitamist of me
it's too good today you're just too good
yeah yeah as well if you're trying to
defend why would I freak winds that we
saw it is even though I think all my
chances
and Mayas in his tank bank and remember
once he's in that time bank at this flag
falls it's over just like folding but
folding the ultimate game when
everything is all
where is that night
America somewhere
all right well at least I'm not the one
singing okay Mario why I've got in the
action and now he's gonna make me pay
it's always a bad sign when your
opponent is singing what to do what to
do what to do what to do and he stole my
gun it is one little time bank is gone
f-five is taking it right - he's taking
it right to me no respect no respect at
all it doesn't sound good that
whatever's happening does that sound
good for Michael J here yeah the more
beeps we can answer the clock the better
you know everybody loves beats
that's not what I be Mari does not want
to be checked that old Napoli momentum
not blame a middle
tell me tell me tell me
oh yeah I let you have that check out
you have that check on
that's just time
oh yeah hates being checked
too bad Mario - OH
see unlike a regular blitz game I still
have really a lot of time to think and
that make stupid mistakes late for my
night they're good for my work there's
all right give the man a check
you really want to do that Mario I don't
think you did it I don't think it did
all right check finally I got something
cooking here fine
after all this time
[Music]
oh all right let's not miss made into
here check who's singing now
[Music]
all right good game Mario boy that was
intense luckily I got the better of
Mario and I didn't miss Mayton - even
though earlier in the game because of
all the intensity I did miss winning his
queen I saw that his knight could go
back to e8 to defend their Bishop but
then I missed that my queen could just
take his queen and game would have been
over
but that's intense chess for you it's
not going to be perfect but it's gonna
be action-packed
all right so you saw what intense chess
is all about and now I am here to
propose the action clock so this is the
best on the market that that plays
intense chess but you saw it has many
flaws like for instance I start the
clock right
it's his time is actually going right
now but you see the action clock is over
here so you would need either one big
action clock with the time ticking down
or an action clock here and there to
show the countdown to both the players
okay and also there is one more element
of intense chess that hopefully can be
incorporated into a high level chess now
I know that these time controls are a
little too fast for the super
grandmasters to play serious chess set
however if we incorporate one more
element of Poker into this it might be
beneficial for tournaments such as the
sync build Cup and the US Chess
Championship prize possibly so we we add
time extensions a 30-second time
extension every time a player makes you
know 20 moves or so that way players can
play a real legitimate game of chess and
there could be heirs involved as you see
but it will enhance the spectator
experience so much that it'll be worth
it you don't have to start all the games
at the same time anymore
during the sync bill cup you can start
them possibly every half hour still have
a nice long broadcast but have it be
intense where it's just back and forth
back and forth you don't see players
getting up walking around for 20 minutes
it's be constant action it'll be great
for the viewers it'll be great for the
players it'll be great for the sponsors
as well so I urge you to try the try it
for yourself see how you like it and
thank you very much for your time